une galère pour les usagers des
autoroutes à1 et à13 ce mardi 9 janvier
des chutes de neige inattendues ont
entraîné la fermeture temporaire de ces
axes jusqu'en fin de matinée en cause
une couche de 1 à 3 cm de neige créant
quelques légers accidents à 10h 196 km
de bouchon étit comptabilisé sur les
routes franciliennes selon les données
trafic citadin des conditions de
circulation difficiles observé également
un peu partout dans le département les
autoroutes n'ont pas été salées
préventivement je je pas en tout cas
elle n'avait pas été salée donc les
autoroutes étaient fermées ce matin pour
permettre le traitement et donc le
trafic qui s'écoule habituellement sur
les autoroutes c'est reporté sur les
routes départementales ce qui a provoqué
de l'engorgement du côté de cant an en
iveline 12 Suses des neigeuses étaient
mobilisé pour assurer la sécurité des
usagers sur l'agglomération un premier
passage des machines a été effectué vers
23h hier soir avant un nouveau passage
dans le courant de l'après-midi une
situation inattendue c'est
particulièrement difficile tout
simplement parce que M au France son on
n pas eu
d'information que la neige allait
tomberé donc on a été pris de cours
fallait faire ça un peu en urgence pour
pouvoir déblayer les rues concernant les
transports en commun les lignes L N et U
ont subi des perturbations à cause des
mauvaises conditions météorologiques des
trains mais aussi des bus ralentis dans
la matinée conséquence à l'université de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline les examens ont
été perturbés j'ai raté tous mes
partiels j'espère que je vais pouvoir
attattraper mon partiel il y a mon bus
qui a éttaé adulé du coup c'était un peu
tendu
pour arriver il y a plein de monde qui
av des problèmes de train notre partie
elle a commencé en retard et la moitié
qui est arrivé à 1 heure pas possible du
coup c'était compliqué ce matin le
préfet des ivelin appelle les usagers de
la route à la plus grande prudence un
épisode que Météo France n'avait pas vu
venir plaçant le département en
vigilance orange neige verglas jusqu'à
demain matin